IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN TRYING TO
PROJECT CONFIDENCE WHILE SOME IN
THE WHITE HOUSE ARE WORRIED WHAT
LIES AHEAD.
CONCERNS OVER THE ECONOMY.
POLITICAL ALLIES ARE FAULTING
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR MIXED
MESSAGING AND GROWING CONCERNS
ABOUT INFLATION.
SOME ECONOMISTS THINK THE
PRESIDENT'S SPENDING PLAN COULD
BE TOO BIG.
THE GAS CRISIS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TOLD AMERICANS
WOULD SOON GO AWAY IS STILL
HAPPENING.
IN WASHINGTON D.C., 71% OF
STATIONS ARE OUT OF GAS AND
OTHER STATES ARE STILL
EXPERIENCING SHORTAGES.
SO WHILE WARNING SIGNS MAY BE
FLASHING, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
TELLING AMERICANS THERE'S
NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
>> WE'VE GONE FROM STAGNATION TO
AN ECONOMY THAT IS GROWING
FASTER THAN IT HAS IN 40 YEARS.
WE'VE GONE FROM ANEMIC JOB
CREATION TO RECORD CREATION FOR
A NEW ADMINISTRATION.
NONE HAS EVER CREATED THIS MANY
JOBS IN THIS TIME FRAME.
PROGRESS IS UNDENIABLE.
>> WHEN YOUR ALLIES ARE
COMPLAINING ABOUT YOUR
MESSAGING, THAT POINTS TO A FACT
PROBLEM, NOT A MESSAGING
PROBLEM.
>> Greg: FIRST OF ALL, I HAD NO
IDEA THAT IT WAS NATIONAL
ROADWORK DAY.
>> IT IS, AS A MATTER OF FACT.
INFRASTRUCTURE WEEK HERE ON "THE
FIVE."
>> Greg: YOU'RE WEARING THE
OFFICIAL COLOR OF THEIR SIGN.
I THINK THAT WAS REALLY
ADMIRABLE.
YOU NEED TO SUPPORT THEM.
>> I TRY TO PARTICIPATE.
>> Greg: I WAS GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE COMMENT BUT THE
PRODUCERS SAID I SHOULD SHUT UP.
LOOK, THERE'S TWO THINGS THAT
BIDEN SAYS.
HE SAYS THE ECONOMY IS GROWING
FASTER IN NEARLY 40 YEARS.
THAT HE ALSO INHERITED AN ANEMIC
ECONOMY.
BUT IT FORCES EVERYBODY ELSE
WHEN YOU HEAR THAT TO DO THE
CLEANUP.
YOU CAN'T FACT CHECK THAT.
YOU HAVE TO DO A COMPLETE FACT
SEX CHANGE.
THE TWO FACTS THAT HE'S PUSHING
ARE ONLY POSITIVE IF YOU PRETEND
THE PANDEMIC DIDN'T EXIST.
THE ECONOMY WAS ANEMIC BECAUSE
OF THE SHUT DOWN.
TO MAKE THAT YOUR PUNCH IS
PATHETIC.
I THINK THAT THE REASON WHY YOU
DON'T SEE HIM OR ANYBODY IN THE
MEDIA TOO WORRIED ABOUT THE GAS
STUFF IS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
DRIVE.
IT'S REALLY IS STUPID.
I'LL MAKE A GENERALIZATION ABOUT
THIS.
MOST PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA DON'T
DRIVE.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO PUMP
THEIR OWN GAS.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY'RE NOT AWARE
OF THE PEOPLE AROUND THEM THAT
NEED GAS THAT RELY ON FUEL.
THE TRUCKERS, THE AMAZON
DELIVERY PEOPLE THAT SEND --
BRING YOUR PILATES MATS, THE
DRIVER THAT BRINGS YOU YOUR THAI
FOOD.
SO YOU MAY NOT DRIVE, BUT OTHER
PEOPLE ARE DOING THE DRIVING FOR
YOU.
>> DAGEN A LOT OF THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE ECONOMY HAVE BEEN
THEORETICAL FOR A LONG TIME LIKE
THE POSSIBILITY OF INFLATION OR
SHORTAGES AND THOSE THINGS
PILING UP.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE, IS THERE
CONCRETE EVIDENCE OF ANY OF
THAT?
>> YES.
JUST REMAINS TO BE SEEN HOW MUCH
PEOPLE'S EXPECTATIONS ARE.
ONCE YOU SEE THE INFLATION,
THAT'S WHEN THE HIGH PRICES ARE
HERE TO STAY FOR A REALLY LONG
TIME.
I'VE ARGUED THIS IS JOE BIDEN'S
AMERICA.
THE REAL WORLD CONSEQUENCES JUST
SHOWED UP A HELL OF A LOT FASTER
THAN THE DEMOCRATS EXPECTED JUST
IN TIME FOR THE MID-TERMS.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE WORRIED.
WHOOPS.
WE'RE GETTING TO SEE WHERE THIS
BIDARIAN BRILLIANCE WILL TAKE
THIS COUNTRY.
OPEN BORDERS, DONE.
HAPPENED QUICKLY.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS, THE
DEMOCRATS COULDN'T MILLION THE
OPTICS.
GAS LINES.
BIDEN PROMISED TO TRANSITION
AWAY FROM THE OIL INDUSTRY.
HALF OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN
IS AIMED AT ELIMINATING FOSSIL
FUELS.
HE KILLED THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE
DAY ONE.
AND JEN GRANHOLM, THE ENERGY
SECRETARY SAYS IF YOU JUST DROVE
AN ELECTRIC CAR, YOU WOULDN'T BE
HAVING A PROBLEM WERE THE
GASOLINE SHORTAGES.
ON TOP OF THAT, YOU HAVE
GOVERNMENT HANDOUTS AND RUN-AWAY
SPENDING THAT IS AN EXTRA $300
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT.
THAT'S NOTHING COMPARED TO THE
FOUR GINORMOUS ENTITLEMENTS.
UNIVERSAL PRE-K, FREE CHILD CAR,
FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE THAT BIDEN HAS
PLANS TO IMPLEMENT BUT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WORK FOR THEM.
HOW DO YOU DO IT?
THE FEDERAL RESERVE KEEPS
PRINTING MONEY, BUYING UP THE
DEBT.
WHAT DO YOU GET?
CRUSHING INFLATION THAT IS A
REGRESSIVE TAX ON PEOPLE THAT
CHOOSE TO WORK.
>> SO WHEN YOU GO TO STORE TO
BUY THINGS, IT COST MORE.
IT'S LIKE A TAX.
SO JUAN, THIS IS THE COVER OF
THE "NEW YORK POST" TODAY.
IT SAYS THAT JOE BIDEN IS
PROVING EVEN MORE OF A MASTER OF
DISASTER THAN JIMMY CARTER.
I'M ASSUMING YOU THINK THAT IS
TOO STRONG.
A CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
>> Juan: I LIKE TABLOIDS AS MUCH
AS THE NEXT GUY TO CATCH MY
ATTENTION AS I'M WALKING PAST
THE NEWS STAND.
BUT IT'S NOT REAL.
LET'S JUST TAKE A LOOK AT THE
PUBLIC OPINION.
PUBLIC OPINION POLLS, JOE BIDEN
IS WELL OVER 50% IN ALMOST ALL
OF THE POLLS.
IN A.P., LIKE 60% APPROVAL.
THAT IS JUST THE REALITY TOUCH.
YOU THINK ABOUT HIS POLICIES IN
TERMS OF DEALING WITH COVID OR
IN TERMS OF HIS INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN.
AGAIN, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE LIKE
THESE POLICIES.
THEY LIKE THE PLAN.
SO I THINK YEAH, HE HAS HIS
CRITICS BUT THE BIG ONE IN TERMS
OF THE POLLS, DANA, IS THAT FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN FOUR YEARS,
MOST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SAY
THE COUNTRY IS ON THE RIGHT
TRACK.
THAT IS SUCH AN OPTIMISTIC
POSITIVE WAY OF SEEING WHAT IS
GOING ON.
JOE BIDEN DESERVES CREDIT FOR
IT.
I'M A DRIVER ESPECIALLY ON
WEEKENDS.
I DON'T HAVE TO DRIVE DURING THE
WEEK.
ON THE WEEKENDS, I GET OUT AND
ABOUT.
I HAVE GAS IN D.C. THIS WEEKEND.
MOST OF THE GAS STATIONS IN
VIRGINIA AND MARYLAND, ADJACENT
JURISDICTIONS, THEY HAVE GAS.
SO I THINK MOST PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND, THIS WASN'T THE WORK
OF ANY POLICY.
THIS IS THE WORK OF HACKERS.
HACKERS FROM RUSSIA.
SO THE FACT THAT IT'S --
EVERYTHING IS BEING RESUPPLIED,
THINGS ARE GETTING BETTER IS A
SIGN AGAIN AMERICA CAN ADJUST
WHEN DIFFICULT TIMES, WHEN
TURBULENCE HITS.
BUT YOU KNOW, JUST OVERALL, I
WANT TO JUST RESPOND TO WHAT I
HEARD.
I THINK THE ECONOMY IS GOING
FROM ZERO STANDSTILL BECAUSE OF
COVID, WE PUT IT IN A SLEEP
ESSENTIALLY AND NOW IT'S COMING
BACK TO LIFE.
IT'S GOING FROM STANDSTILL TO
HYPER SPEED AND THERE'S
TURBULENCE.
YOU MAY NOT HAVE YOUR
CHICK-FIL-A SAUCES.
YOU MAY HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
KETCHUP HERE, LUMBER THERE.
IT'S LIKE A TAKE-OFF WHEN YOU
HIT A TURBULENCE.
EVERY BIG SIGN, STOCK MARKETS,
TREASURY BONDS, ALL GOOD STUFF.
>> JESSE, THAT WAS LIKE WINDING
YOU UP.
I'LL LET YOU GO FROM THERE.
>> Jesse: YEAH.
JUAN IS NOT PANICKING.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS.
YOU SLAW THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
DOESN'T PANIC?
THERE'S THREE REPORTS THAT SAY
THEY'RE PANICKING THAT MEANS
IT'S TEN TIMES WORSE THAN
THEY'RE SAYING.
BIDEN IS PROBABLY HAVING HIS DOG
BITE PEOPLE HE'S SO ANGRY.
THE REASON WHY INFLATION, JUAN,
IS SUCH A POLITICAL KILLER IS
BECAUSE IT AFFECTS THE LEFT AND
THE RIGHT EQUALLY.
IT AFFECTS THE POOR AND THE RICH
UNEQUALLY.
SO IT GIVES RISE TO POPULISM.
SOMETHING THAT JOE BIDEN BARELY
TAMED AND IS STILL BOILING
BENEATH THE SURFACE.
FORGET ABOUT WHAT IT CAN DO.
SETS BACK COUNTRIES YEARS.
IT HAPPENS BECAUSE YOU SPEND AND
PRINT TOO MUCH MONEY.
SO WE'VE ASKED FOR IT.
JOE BIDEN'S $300 WEEKLY BONUS IS
NOW CREATING A HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
SITUATION.
YOU COMBINE INFLATION, HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT, YOU GET STA
STAGFLATION.
IT SOUNDS GOOD TO SAY BUT A
HORRIBLE THINGS TO EXPERIENCE.
THE ONLY THING YOU CAN DO TO
BEAT STAGFLATION IS RAISE RATES
AND STOP PRINTING MONEY.
WHEN YOU DO THAT, THE ECONOMY
SUFFERS.
SO WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO?
JOE BIDEN HAS TO ACT.
THE LONGER YOU WAIT, THE HARDER
IT IS TO TAKE CARE OF.
JOE BIDEN'S TOOL BOX IS LIMITED
BECAUSE ANYTHING HE TRIES, THE
LEFT WILL FREAK OUT.
IF HE SAYS HEY, REPUBLICANS,
MAYBE I'LL LOWTER COST OF MY
PLAN, THEY'LL FREAK OUT.
IF HE SAID LET'S STOP THE BORDER
INFLUX SO WE CAN RAISE WAGES,
LEFT WILL FREAK OUT.
IF HE SAYS, YOU KNOW, ENERGY
PRODUCERS, LET'S TRY TO INCREASE
SUPPLY, TAKE SOME PRESSURE OFF,
LEFT WILL FREAK OUT.
EVENTUALLY FED WILL HAVE TO JUMP
IN.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO RAISE
RATES.
IT'S GOING TO HURT THE ECONOMY.
BIDEN WILL DO JUST WHAT BARACK
OBAMA DID.
BLAME HIS PREDECESSOR FOR THE
BAD RECOVERY.
>> REMEMBER THAT?
GET A MOP.
BY THE WAY, GREG, I WORE THIS IN
HONOR OF YOUR LOGO.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT SO.
IT'S THAT OR CIRCUIT PEANUTS.
>> YOU LIKE THOSE?
>> Greg: NO